good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day we are
because it's another day of Jackson
Cloud original recipe 2022 version of us
back in the studio Jackson Cloud wearing
new merch 2023. no it's 2022 in 2023. is
that what you're saying like I said it
yesterday and you kind of like didn't
get it then and then we're so involved
that like honestly go backwards I'm not
20 22 Jacks I'm not 20 21. Jax you're
certainly I'm just saying 2022 Club
visually like we are in terms of the
setup giving old energy we are except
vintage we are in a sense I understand
what you're saying the vibe is similar
but there we're so new and fresh
especially today in our new fresh merch
which is our First Merch drop with our
new logo yes it has also just been a
while since we've done a merch drop we
wanted to really make this one cute we
know you guys love our crewnecks and for
summer I'm obsessed with these first of
all color-wise they're so summery so
summery they're so light they're not
like really heavy or I'm not sweating I
love we're coming up with two different
um crewnecks I'm wearing the pink one
obviously Jackie's wearing the teal one
the one Jackie's wearing has our new
logo on the left breast as you can see
if you're watching on YouTube and then
when you flip it around we got our brand
new logo oh you just hold it in place
yeah great logo
it's so cute again really thin good
material perfect for like you know a
Cool Spring evening it's not like a long
sleeve these are the same crew necks as
the other pink and teal ones we did the
sorority sorority yeah yeah and of
course we're gonna come out with a few
uh matching accessories like phone cases
and mugs and stuff but the merch
launched the official Rebrand lurch
merch launch is tomorrow Wednesday the
Thursday
Wednesday oh Wednesday the 19th speed on
these things and I am Wednesday the 19th
at 10 A.M eastern time our website is
toast merch all the information will be
on our Instagram so we will never let
you forget but I'm excited it's been a
while yeah I'm excited too these are
such fun sweatshirts it's been a while
since I've had like fresh merch I feel
like so much of my merch I've worn it to
the to the Bone and I wash it so much
that like the pink is no longer pink
okay you were right I was right yeah no
I was I was like I'm for sure right but
let me just double check launching 420
Theo's birthday day of the gone it's
Theo's birthday merch wow it's Theo's
birthday March launch I'm so sorry it's
4 20. that's so easy to remember so we
won't be
counting how many candles for his cake
no we will be dropping merch exactly
that's what Theo would want 100 because
he supports business he's a businessman
though 4 20 10 a.m eastern time
um toastmerch.com I'm so excited I'm so
excited as well I'm really excited about
the new logo the I love this like teal
one it's just so
so simple yeah and Polished did you show
everyone yours because yours is not no
so we have two different designs the
ones Jackie's wearing is you know very
much logo classic classic the classic
and this one's more of like um like a
like a self-expression if that makes
sense it's more expressive
so here we have turdy Lou wearing the
new the toast pink slash Coral crew neck
she looks gorgeous in it she's wearing a
size large I too am wearing a size large
and I like the size large it's actually
a really nice large it's a large that
feels like a real large I agree it's
like a it's roomy yeah I love I can't
wear like
people who wear like crewnecks fitted in
their regular size like are truly insane
yeah well no if you that's what you like
just get whatever crew neck you want oh
yeah I forgot we're talking about a
business here and people who do that are
so cool like you should all just like
buy whatever you want no it's a cute
like it is cute when other people do
it's just not cute on me no me neither
no you know no no need to yaka there's
yums but that's literally what I do for
a living it's true
um so I'm so excited about that I'm just
excited to be sitting here with you me
another great show and hopefully great
show we do have good stories oh good
okay no TV recap today because there was
nothing on last night correct correct
I've just been reading my book which is
getting pretty good I like it good and
we're just feeling how are you feeling
I'm feeling like a little agitated why
could not sleep
my sleep wasn't glorious actually my
sleep was pretty crappy it was probably
worse than yours but I've stopped but
mine was so short I stopped noticing
mine was short too what time did you go
to bed I went to bed around 11 but like
sleeping in fits and starts and then
Harry woke us up at 5 30. why I don't I
don't know and he then he went back to
sleep but like I didn't uh-huh and then
I did go back to sleep from like 7 30 to
8 15. oh that like doesn't count no it's
something I honestly have forgotten
about it until you started complaining
oh sorry no I mean
I was up from 11 30 to 2 30 like and I
was thinking I was trying to pinpoint
why I
couldn't sleep like it didn't make sense
you know I didn't have like anything
really particularly on my mind and
I didn't drink any soda I can't drink
soda after like three o'clock now I'm
like a grandma and or like even a
Snapple like caffeine really hits me
and I was like were you hungry
not really I had to switch up for dinner
I had some steak that I reheated I was
talking about my steak yesterday and
then I got a little hungry a few hours
later and Ben had actually left some
Froyo in the uh yeah like it was a it
was a totally like good meal
and then I actually think even after
that I had a nice Pop I was really
hungry but the show you were hungry
because hunger can keep you up but like
like I know when I'm hungry I wasn't
hungry like I ate a [__] ton you know
and then I was trying to pinpoint like
maybe I took something in the day that
was I couldn't figure it out but I have
been experiencing like I don't even want
to talk about it because like it makes
me so upset but like I have been
experiencing like like hair loss you
could talk about it open up I really
don't want to because like it makes me
really upset and like I actually could
cry because the one thing I've had in
this life is my hair I have been ugly I
have been beautiful like my hair has
always been with me like I have been
canceled I've been not like do you know
what I mean like yeah my hair is always
with me I feel so connected to my hair
except for that one year in eighth grade
when you cut a chore yes that was a very
dark time thank you for bringing that up
that was like actually probably one of
the ugliest I've ever been except you
were so cute no no okay okay I totally
forgot about that oh my God that was
really bad why'd you guys let me do that
I you know you got to try new things and
good thing you didn't do it later in
life so true when like it actually
mattered right
so I've just been experiencing like
really bad I don't even know what to
call it if it's like thinning or
shedding basically
um like I've noticed over the last like
two months every time I brush my hair or
do my hair it's like crazy and Ben has
had to like snake or drain like on a
weekly basis because my hair is just
like it's like kind of falling out and
people haven't noticed and it's because
I have so much hair and I'm so grateful
for that but like now I just have like
honestly a normal amount of hair
um it's just been like giving me
terrible anxiety and so you had the
great idea like a few days ago for me to
start taking prenatal vitamins I'm not
pregnant because we're waiting for all
the things that you ordered to come and
you were hanging out with me and my
prenatals were right there and I was
like they are great for Hair Skin and
nail growth Nails yeah
um so it's like just take it while you
wait for your other things so that's
what I've been doing I've been taking
biotin
um of course heard like I've gotten so
many good recommendations people
honestly so many people recommended
neutral fall which is how I first found
out about it but um then last night I
was like oh my god did I take my
prenatal vitamins too late just prenatal
vitamins have caffeine like I could not
figure out why I was being [__] kept
awake no I take mine at like 11 o'clock
I was like oh my God how did I not think
of course there's caffeine pregnant
women need caffeine
no we like we can have a little bit but
we would prefer to get it from a coffee
I thought it was like your daily dose of
pregnant caffeine no no no no no no it's
like your daily dose of like folic acid
so important to have folic acid yeah for
the follicles oh my God I don't know I
don't know if that's related but it
sounds good so it's just something I'm
dealing with and I've like always just
heard of other people I know through you
obviously but that was like pregnancy
related so it's like much more common
yeah
um Olivia before she was a mom had
experienced bad hair loss and like it
was so traumatizing for her and like it
was just something I never had to deal
with and I kind of like like felt like
right above it yeah I felt like I was
better than everyone like that wasn't
gonna be a problem for me
and obviously I know it's because of
like I've had a recent you know drastic
change in diet like I know the reasoning
that's yeah it just [__] sucks like
it does but like it should give you
solace that the reason is actually
really great reason like you've lost a
lot of weight so you know everything is
like a given take it doesn't make sense
like I'm so much healthier now like
shouldn't my hair reflect that
yeah like I'm eating more nutrient dense
food like I'm having salads multiple
times a week before when my hair was so
thick I had a salad since like 1997.
yeah so it just doesn't make sense
that's just something I'm dealing with
and like honestly I didn't want to talk
about it because like every time I do I
start crying it's just like my hair is
so important to me well no one could
tell I certainly couldn't tell okay from
your actual head of hair and I'm just
curious like okay so my hair is falling
out but like why isn't the leg hair
falling out you know why does it happen
why isn't my bush falling out you know
it's so annoying that's why the human
body like makes no sense oh I'm having
hair loss okay at least I could benefit
a little bit from it okay here's the
thing though with your leg hair and your
bush were falling out also then that
would have to mean your eyebrows and
your eyelashes were falling out ooh
straight back straight backs so I think
we should leave things as they are
okay that's true that's true perspective
key key well thank you for opening up
turdy you're welcome leave all I'm glad
that everyone who has experienced hair
loss before you can give you all their
tips and tricks and that you caught it
really before anyone besides you and me
noticed yeah like I noticed it but like
I can't in the beginning it really
didn't bother me like I was thinking
like you know I have so much hair and if
I lose a tenth of it and maybe it'll
help me like do my hair quicker but then
it got to a point where like when I put
my hair up in a ponytail you can like
see a lot of my scalp and that like
freaks me out because that just makes
you look like so scary
it's okay yeah so that's what I'm
dealing with and maybe that was keeping
you up no it wasn't actually I actually
actually didn't even think about my hair
loss last night I was like so
wanting to kill someone also when that
could keep you up the anger yes so true
it's a vicious cycle
um also Ben wasn't home and when Ben's
not home like I can't sleep yeah the
house was making sounds and I just read
this like Thriller
which one
Seraphina no well I did just read on a
quiet street by Seraphina
um but it was tough because I read a
book and I didn't like it we were
talking about this I facetimed you
because I needed advice yeah yeah what
do you do and this is a definitely like
a niche problem I don't think this is
like a relatable thing no it's extremely
Niche what do you do when you dislike a
book and you want to like you know warn
others that like you didn't like it or
not recommend it and you're like known
for your book Rex and also like you know
there are some books you don't like so
you have to share your truth and so what
do you do when you want to share that
truth but you are told that the author
um someone responded to the story right
when you posted it saying the author
follows you and I'm pretty sure she's a
patreon member I don't know how they
would know that but then she did follow
me so then I was like oh maybe she has a
patreon member and I deleted it because
and I just want to say it's not
reflective of this author I read this
book because I loved another book that
she wrote this one was just like silly
like it wasn't for me
um
and I just deleted it immediately and
like I don't run into this problem a lot
because if a author follows me I think
it's because I like their books and then
they see that I like them yeah so like
Ellen Hildebrand is always just it's
always good congratulatory and yeah
everyone just patting each other I've
never disliked an Ellen Hildebrand book
I've liked more others more than than
some but
what do you do is this a problem you run
into as a reed head yes it not so much
that I know for a fact that someone saw
something that I didn't like and you
know it was their book but I always have
it in mind and I feel like there are
some authors who who are just like girly
swirlies and then there are some who who
would literally never know you yeah if
you can tell when they're definitely not
listening to the toes right so when it's
like a book like that I'll give my my
speak my truth on it but that is why
even though I'm pretty you know in the
book scene and a book flew into her I'm
not trying to like establish authorial
relationships yeah because I just want
to be able to read books and share my
opinion and that's why you don't have
like you've had authors who like
publicist reach out to come up the whole
reason why but like it's it's part of it
but I do actually in order to maintain
like your integrity almost I would like
to have more authors on the redheads
this is something we talked about
probably on a patreon like to do two
episodes a month where it's like one is
the book of the month interview either
an author or like a fellow book
influencer a big reader there's so many
different like facets
um I just don't have the time right now
but like if I ever find myself with like
more time on my hands and I want to
expand and do more like that's what I
would do another episode of redheads
where like I talked to authors that I
like and
um just chit chat about books it's so
funny how we both have like contingency
plans like if we ever if I think that's
not that's not a contingency no no what
I mean contingency plan like for our
um extra time oh what's yours I start a
podcast with Ben like I've been saying
forever but the problem isn't time it's
content no no no it really is
once a week that's fine I like I
actually at this current juncture not
being on tour I could I could get it
done but what would you talk about we
figured out no that's not a recipe for a
podcast no no we would figure it out
like the first we would figure it out
like I don't I also don't like when
podcasts are so um
structured to the point where it's like
yes every podcast needs like a niche but
I think some people like pigeonhole
themselves into that Niche so deeply yes
but you need a niche otherwise yeah but
I think our Niche is just like cuddly
like fighting like you know what I mean
no no I know that that would be like a
part of the show but you need a
structure other structure yeah of course
other and you need like a concept I
don't think so honestly no not for Ben
and I you're a bit different no no I
think certain certain podcasts even
certain people we need a concept culture
no work Fast Five
yeah that's structure like that's a
segment it's a concept like Ben and I
would have segments for sure it wouldn't
just be like an hour-long ramble like
similar to Good Guys what category would
it be comedy we'd be competing with
ourselves it wouldn't be like
relationships is that no because I don't
think we would be giving relationship
advice like honestly I don't think
anybody like needs that and you know
what you know I'm so glad you brought
that up I don't think you can start
another comedy podcast with someone else
like that would hurt me oh wow I think
that would hurt all right I put it in
lifestyle okay and society and culture
redheads yeah I'll put in the Arts
um you just reminded me of something
I've been noticing something lately that
I just find interesting and I have
thoughts on but I would love to get your
thoughts on is
there seems to be like a and I think
it's similar to the conversation we were
just having where people not even in
just podcasting but in content Creation
in general really want to create like
niches for themselves so they make
themselves like an expert in something
right and they've noticed like a lot of
people gravitate towards becoming a
dating expert and they do like q and A's
and they like but you know that that
person what makes them sometimes they're
even single which not like there's
nothing wrong with being single but how
the [__] does that make you a dating
expert and these people have just kind
of like branded themselves there's like
a few people who come to mind Brandon
themselves as like the experts on dating
and like everything they do is like
advice segments and Q and A's and it's
like well why you yeah what makes you
qualified no what who's more of an
expert I'm dating like these are two
extremes like uh extremely single person
who has 100 boyfriend in let's say 10
years but is going on a lot of dates
someone who got married off of her first
date I don't know someone who's only
been on a date with one person and she's
so successful this she's a dating expert
I think I'm a relationship expert yeah
no and those are extremes and obviously
you know it's somewhere in the middle
but I do think if you're perpetually
single
maybe you're not the dating expert or
you are because you go on so many dates
but it's clearly not working like you
know I don't know I just find it so
interesting like so many people have
just kind of like created this like
like brand and like market for
themselves as like dating and it's like
well what the [__] makes you qualified
no and I'm trying to think who I would
take dating advice from not that I
needed right now but like who right now
I just would have been like in the past
right of course you know we at that time
it was like Patty stanker yeah I think
you would lean towards like an older
woman because you have like much more
traditional like you're very much like
chivalry I'm not paying for dinner yeah
honestly I wouldn't take dating advice
from someone in their 20s hot take yeah
or I don't know yeah definitely I I
wouldn't even take dating advice from me
no I would take dating advice from like
someone with kids no just someone who's
a lit like who like sorry I didn't mean
someone kids I meant like someone old
someone older someone who's lived who
like has wisdom I just find it
interesting I think they're like a
Eternal dating truths yeah and people
keep trying to reinvent it but like I
think that there are Eternal truths it's
so true Timeless Timeless you're right
that is interesting
yeah no and I think it's smart I think
like for business reasons like they end
up working with like a lot of Brands who
are like dating apps and it just it's
it's good to have like a thing when
you're a content creator who's just
sharing their life because you're
competing with everyone but if you have
like a little small Niche like I totally
get it but I just find it interesting
because people do submit questions and
seek out advice from this person it's
like well why why yeah what makes them
qualified
yeah like I think people seek out our
advice or not advice our thoughts on pop
culture takes and I feel qualified to
give that like I have been a fan of Pop
Culture since I was born I know
everything that goes on on this planet
oh not even that but just I think more
of the advice that we give is like
relationship advice to an extent and not
so much advice but just like sharing our
experience and then saying and do
without what you will yeah but I feel
like
with your toasters like we get it but we
don't Bill ourselves this like
relationship experts no and we get
submissions for like all different types
of things like hygiene friendship yeah
but like just giving our thoughts people
I think come to us because they might be
in a similar stage of life like
newlyweds or married a few years
starting to have kids and like you just
kind of and if your friends aren't in
that place like you just want it's like
chit chat with your girlies I don't go
to my friends that's it for like advice
necessarily but kind of like
commiseration yeah of course maybe
that's what it is like maybe people are
gravitating towards content creators who
are in like a similar life stages them
yeah that's a different thing but I then
I wouldn't say it's just like it feels
like a friend but I do feel like that's
what influencers are to a lot of their
fans sometimes in a really nice way
where it's like we're all going through
this I'm gonna do it publicly so that we
like you feel seen and we're doing it
together I guess a good example of
somebody who's done that but I think
successfully is like Nick vile
like he wrote a book on like he's really
like becoming like a millennial sort of
Patty stanger-ish
um but you know he went like on a dating
show multiple times like I actually feel
like that gives you a resume of sorts
yeah also also he's 40. like he's lived
quite quite a bit yeah and now that he's
engaged it it's all good but also he
just gave good advice you know like very
rational so if you give good advice then
you can you can do it yeah yeah I just
find it interesting but that is a good
example but I I would he does give good
advice he has like a whole second
podcast like right yeah like ask Nick or
whatever yeah
so he's giving a male perspective that's
like yeah that's his value that's the
hook that's his value yeah yeah that's
true
um so it's just like one of the the few
things that were on my mind last night
when I couldn't fall asleep I understand
well what was on your mind
um a lot you know I kept thinking like
should I pick up my book or am I like
now dedicating two hours to not sleeping
yeah yeah yeah but then I fell asleep I
can't remember I feel like I fell asleep
with my Kindle in my bed which like I
never do that is so cute but I didn't
even turn it on I was just like just in
case I'm always sitting with my Kindle
in my lab like for hours before I
actually like press it oh yeah unless
I'm in a good book but you know it's a
bad book if like you don't press it 100
uh so did you read while you were up no
I had I read the whole night like and
then I finished my book at around like
10 30. and tried to go to bed at like 11
30 and it was just torture so
I hate not being able to fall asleep
like there there are a few it's like a
living hell it's like a Purgatory
there's nothing else going on at some
point like your phone kind of dies down
there's nothing online like worth
watching but you shouldn't be on your
phone and I really wasn't you didn't
look at it once no I looked at it a few
times you shouldn't have but like I was
taking like 30 minute breaks in between
like if 30 minutes if you're not falling
asleep no but you're you're like
counteracting all of the relaxation
you're doing I know it's annoying but
it's literally like and I did two things
like telling your brain hey [__] I'm
awake I did two hatch restful like I did
that's good a guided meditation and I
took a lavender trip through a lavender
field
did that help no
people wasn't your night turdy it wasn't
my night today's a new day yeah no need
to focus on the past yay
has where'd you get that coffee I made
it where here with the Starbucks like
things here well I grabbed a cup of ice
from the bodegas yeah your people yeah
your favorite why are you like what's
with the I don't know because I agree
because I like kind of went out of my
way to get a copy and then like you I
didn't ask you if I wanted one no you
wouldn't like it and you show up like
with a coffee that looks really good and
I know you didn't go out of your way for
it no so I was just wondering like where
it came from it's store-bought ice
with homemade coffee
in a cup from
the store-bought ice
they gave me the cup what is with the
third degree I just I just like to know
what you're up to I things have changed
around here since I've been back you
know since you left yeah since I left
and that's what happens you leave people
and they're forced to change and grow
good it looks good you have a nice cup
of coffee yeah welcome that's what
happens yeah welcome that's what force
you to grow that's what happened I don't
see the problem that's what happened
good things are happening that's what
happened great things
all right what do you say yeah let's get
into it because we have some more
debating to do in today's story oh yes
I'm very excited there's like one story
I'm sure everyone has seen it or if you
haven't you will that's really
like it's dividing the nation I was
reading comments I I wanted I am
inexperienced it's about motherhood so
like it's later in the show it's the
story about like uh Jesse James Decker's
sister which is just like an added layer
on the plane because it's not about
Jesse James it's about this MLB player's
wife yeah it depends what publication
you're reading People magazine Jesse
James Decker's sister New York Post MLB
Blue Jays pictures wife
um on the plane with her kids and what
happened next and it's an ensuing a lot
of passionate responses from people and
I think I'm excited to have this
conversation me too uh so without
further uh did it did it do here are the
fast five stories that you didn't do
need to know
that is true before I say the stories I
have something to say wow the tables
have turned because I want to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by Dreamland baby it's also
pronounced Dreamland Bebe But whichever
you prefer I read that in the company
bylines guidelines so I want to
introduce you to a product that over
half a million parents including me use
to help their baby sleep it's the
Dreamland baby weighted sleep sacks and
swaddles so if you are a mama eat new or
one-year-old two-year-olds like sleep
sacks are everything and Dreamland baby
has the best sleep sack because they
have weighted sleep sacks that have
patented cover com technology which
evenly distributes weight from the
baby's shoulder to toes it naturally
reduces stress allowing your little one
to relax and sleep soundly so baby sleep
is the eighth wonder of the world and
there's so many products that try and
solve this and really nothing is as
powerful as a sleep sack a weighted
sleep sack and then on top of that the
Dreamland baby sleep sack because
the interior of the Sleep sack
especially if you have a newborn it
bundles the arms from the inside and
then zips on the outside so they really
can't wake themselves up with their arms
the weighted it's like you know how it
feels to wear weighted right it's all
calming helps with anxiety for us but
for baby it just it helps them it feels
almost like there's a person there you
know sometimes babies fall asleep with
your hand on them and if you move it
they'll wake up and but that's like what
weighted sleep sack is about so I'm so
excited to tell you about Dreamland baby
if you are on the sleep
train grind you need to know about it
and the best news is that they're
offering an exclusive discount to the
toast listeners just had had to
Dreamland
babyco.com Pages slash toast and use
code toast at checkout to get 20 off and
put your sleepless nights to rest so
yeah welcome for that today's episode is
also brought to you by bowling Branch
wake up feeling rested and refreshed
with the softest most luxurious sheets
from bowl and brown Greenland for baby
bowling Branch for adults bowling branch
is the best is the best and the betting
experts they're making the highest
quality sheets with Incredible
craftsmanship each set is slow made for
an unmatched softness with 100 traceable
organic cotton that gets softer with
every wash so you know it's no secret
Jackson I are bowling Branch girlies her
entire home my entire home we both have
the signature hemmed sheet collection it
goes from Twin up to California King it
comes in a bunch of different colors I
like the crisp white it looks very
Hamptons very Nancy Myers so why they're
the best is because they use the highest
quality 100 organic cotton threads on
Earth each set of sheets is slow made
for Superior softness they're buttery
soft they're perfect for the the cooler
and the warmer weather is because
they're super breathable they're loved
by millions of sleepers and they're even
been they've even been loved by four U.S
presidents they come in 10 different
colors they're designed to feel
incredible for all sleepers they're made
without toxins they're uh they fit the
deepest mattress so you don't have to
like you know keep every morning waking
up and putting the fitted sheet back on
and the fitted sheet has a top and a
bottom tag so when you're doing your
sheets you'll always put it on the right
way and you don't have to exert any
extra energy you can sleep better at
night with bowl and brand sheets get 15
off your first order when you use promo
code toast at bowlingbranch.com that's
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusion Supply Seaside for
details we didn't even plan this but the
whole episode is really about sleep
why because of your whole yeah no I know
and then is there a short answers no I'm
just saying like I thought you said well
like our whole intro segment was like a
segue it's about better sleep if only we
like knew and like acted like that like
wasn't you know it wouldn't have been as
good it's organic yeah and now you know
like we prioritize sleep and these are
two Sleep Products that we love I
thought we had a story like uh no about
sleepiness maybe we can make something
bad sleep but I actually am moving the
stories around because I'm gonna talk
we're gonna talk about the plain story
okay right
um nothing else is like that crazy so
Jesse James Decker reveals her pregnant
sister cried as she was made to clean
her kids's mess on a flight so this
whole story started a few days ago when
Anthony bass who is an MLB player posted
a tweet it's a picture of his two kids
they're five and two he said the flight
attendant at United just made my 22-week
pregnant wife traveling with a
five-year-old and two-year-old get on
her hands and knees to pick up the
popcorn Mess by my youngest daughter are
you kidding me and then people started
responding like Mo a lot of the comments
are like clean up after your kids right
um then Jesse also posted an Instagram
story saying my sister Sydney Ray bass
just texted me from her flight on United
as you know she is five months pregnant
high risk and also traveling alone with
her two small children Blair
accidentally spilled some popcorn in the
aisle and the flight attendant came up
to Sydney with a trash bag and a wet
wipe telling her the captain wants
Sydney to clean up every drop my poor
sister is on her hands and knees crying
in the aisle completely humiliated and
exhausted with her children while
everyone else watched way to go united
and then she also said um if popcorn is
a hazard why are they giving it on
planes y'all this is just because
apparently the flight attendant told
Sydney that the popcorn in the aisle
would be a hazard also if it's anyone
needs to know the
United the flight gave the popcorn to
the kids they didn't bring their own
popcorn
um so there's so many different layers
here and of course I I do defer to you
and that's why I sent the the story in
our family chat because at first I was
like you know yeah like clean up after
your kids like
yeah
um but then I thought about it more
um and this is so like not the point but
I do not really understand why like a
woman of means like your husband plays
in the MLB like doesn't have a nanny and
now that I'm saying everyone should have
a nanny but it's like you're so worried
about your pregnant wife traveling with
two kids or why don't you pay someone to
fly with her what husband that was just
an additional thought I had not my core
argument no and the only reason we're
even hearing about this story is because
he's an MLB and he tweeted about it but
this could be any gay person and I think
a lot of people were turned off by his
tweet because it's like all right are
you playing the MLB like you have
extraordinary means like why is your
high risk pregnant wife flying alone
without you with two kids like maybe
someone should help her like shh I guess
but that didn't even occur to me like I
think it's nice she's fine with the two
kids she's like doing it all and
I think it it a lot of people have the
question like who cleans up the plane
yeah and it was my understanding that a
cleaning crew comes in between each
flight yes and cleans up the plane you
know a little vacuum I've seen them they
they do and they do a great job a little
vacuum yeah a bare minimum yeah it's not
you know five stars but they get the
plane clean right they rearrange it they
wipe some things down yeah I think I
would assume they wipe down all the
surfaces like the tray tables they
vacuum the floor because everyone adults
too I don't think they wipe down every
trade table especially since they
couldn't handle a couple pieces of
popcorn okay they've everybody leaves
them as adults too right so yes there is
a cleaning crew although I did see and I
don't know if this is verified at all I
haven't seen that what you're about to
say anywhere okay well I did see it but
it was just in a comment so I don't know
if it's true that this was a um United
like one of those really small flights
like United actually doesn't operate it
always says like operated by Skywest you
know or Republic Airways
um and those really small Regional
flights actually don't have cleaning
crews come on the flight attendants
clean the flight okay I don't know if
that's true here's a picture of the
plane seats it's a two yes one side
looks like a regular plane two no two on
one side is like that really small
Regional plane
it's usually three yeah no but like not
really small not really small okay
whatever I think it's irrelevant it is
right hundreds of dollars for a seat on
a plane it is irrelevant I believe I
thought at this time you're paying for
all of the services including like
entering on a clean plane and having a
plane cleaned after you the idea it's
not like she vomited in the middle of
the island it's a couple pieces of
popcorn so this woman is traveling she's
pregnant she has two kids even if she
was just pregnant to make her get down
on her hands and he's like what happened
to decency what like it used to be if
someone's pregnant and I haven't even
seen so much like pregnancy disrespect
but like you give up their seat for them
yeah then make them get on their hands
and knees and start picking up pieces of
popcorn either leave the popcorn there
or help her right and I don't know what
the laws in the sky are like and it's
entirely possible like yeah it was her
responsibility to clean up after her
kids but to be look if you're a half
decent [__] human being uh oh and
you're a flight attendant like you just
help the pregnant lady who's traveling
like hey maybe maybe it's not in your
job description I don't know what the
bylaws of United maybe it's not your
responsibility to clean up after this
kid no I don't think it's the flight
attendant's responsibility so even if
it's not but you're like a a decent
person you just [__] help right or
like you're okay so the popcorn's in the
Isleta Hazard kick it to the side with
your shoe yeah like I don't know it's
not again it's not like the kid had
diarrhea it's like they're treating this
plane like it's the Louvre and it's just
it's a [__] plane and people are
disgusting it's a kid who's two years
old you gave her popcorn and she drops
them on the floor what did you expect
first of all right yeah
and I think you know being dramatic and
saying the captain says it's a hazard
well if it's such a big safety hazard
you know a flight attendant's number one
priority and responsibility is safety
they always say that in the little
message before you take off so if it's
really such a big deal then it actually
it would land on you yeah
I just feel like a lot of people are
debating like well who's responsible and
it's like well maybe it's not who's
responsible because I don't know who's
responsible who has a heart yeah like
just [__] help this one no it's like
the same way when you get on a plane if
you're a pregnant woman traveling with
two kids and you need help putting your
bags up like people come and they help
you yep and sure it's your
responsibility to be able to handle your
kids back right sure but like we're
human beings and like sometimes you can
just like
do something helpful and for no reason
other than take the load off of someone
especially like when it's a pregnant
mother no totally
like we really lost sight we did I think
the reason why people lost sight and
this is what I was trying to say before
is because like the Tweet came from
somebody like in a position of wealth
and power it's like nobody's inclined to
feel bad
because like there were many things that
like this person could have done to
avoid a situation like this that other
people can't do so I think if this had
just been like a regular person saying
this story not like a famous wealthy
person I don't think they're like that
famous no but they have means okay are
you playing the MLB like you you're fine
really yeah
I don't know I've never like
let's see his contract
he signed a two-year five million dollar
contract with the Marlins yeah like just
okay she's like hire some help for your
wife um but so I think that's why people
are having the current debate that
they're actually not the comments like I
was reading the comments from Twitter
and also like some news Publications
posted on Instagram so I was reading in
the comments and all the comments were
like clean up after your kids it's not
our problem to clean it like and it's
like it takes a village to raise a child
like how to get a make a pregnant woman
get on her hands and knees to pick up
some pieces of popcorn again like it's
popcorn yeah we'd be having a different
conversation if the kid like crapped on
the floor like that's sorry Mom that's
on you like that is that is disturbing
to the entire plane and the whole
environment and like yeah that's a
problem but it's like they went out of
their way to like torture this woman
because the popcorn probably wasn't
bothering anyone it didn't smell it's
not a [__] Hazard let's be real okay
so they went out of their way to like
humiliate this person yeah and it and I
was thinking you know
not that it's on anyone else but like
why didn't anyone around like if I saw a
pregnant woman on her hands and he's
like I would get up and help her like as
a passenger yeah
and nobody did
yeah I mean sometimes you don't know
what's going who people have their
headphones that's true you're not paying
attention please people like watch
people get murdered and they film it
like they're gonna start getting up and
help to help clean up the popcorn yeah
yeah that's true those facts yeah so I
don't know I think it's a little you
know a little bit of a Power Trip it is
a little bit of a power to like stand
over and watch it's like
let's just call those people This
Woman's a [__] [__] like she's a
[__] maybe she didn't have to help but
she should have
and I don't think you get into flight
attending if you're not a people person
and This Woman's clearly like a [__]
yeah also I'm not sure that the flight
attendant was a woman oh actually it's
like kind of a really good point I Feel
Like a Woman Like wouldn't do this yeah
might have more they just did they not
use pronouns when no the flight
attendant the flight attendant the
flight attendant oh that's interesting
yeah does it change the story
no no but I would like to know I'm just
curious now I don't know what makes it
worse or better
if it's a man or a woman I guess if it's
a man it makes it worse yeah no but then
if it's like a woman like from your
you're being betrayed by your own
General but like men should help women
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like if a female flight attendant didn't
help put the bag up I wouldn't be as
like and it was just like watching as
opposed to a male and yeah not helping
I'd be like help no that's a really good
point yeah yeah there's so many layers
there's you know there's a lot of like
facts people want to know they're like
where did the popcorn come from how old
was the kid how far along is it like
what was she wearing right no it's could
you tell she was pregnant you know I was
thinking that too um I feel like you
could she's 22 22 and she's like a small
girl and um like if you see her like
Instagram she's probably visibly
pregnant got it yeah she's popping hmm
it's a very interesting story and and I
was reading a lot of people's takes
because honestly I was like and I called
Brian I was like you're like the expert
because I was so curious I'm like what
is the protocol here because like who's
worth like whose job description is it
honestly is it on you know the
passengers to tidy up before they leave
like I don't know it's like is it how
like it's like a hotel it's not on you
to clean up like you know that's the
service you're paying for so Brian like
had it heard really that much about it
and people have been asking him to make
a video and he's like I need to do my
like I need to he didn't want to say he
needs to answer these questions yeah
yeah so he needed to research before but
I really want him to speak on it because
he's like he's an expert but he's also a
parent I feel like he would have a
really unique
perspective not even unique a
well-rounded perspective yeah but like
whose job is it in that scenario
I don't know
I don't know and I think I don't know
that it's anyone's responsibility and
even the person who's if she's
responsible to clean after her kids like
you can still help even though it's not
technically your responsibility I
definitely feel like in terms of flight
attendant culture that I've kind of just
been an observer of in the last couple
of years I know like the priority of
being a flight attendant is you're there
for the safety there's also an element
of service and I do also I feel like the
service element
has become smaller and smaller in the
sense that like I'm afraid to ask for a
drink like when they come over at the
card They just like they shove it in
your face like they're doing you a favor
if you're like falling asleep and like
you don't want to miss it you're like
wake me up yeah yeah it's my one chance
it's like when you think of how far
we've come from like the flight
attendants of Pan Am right to the flight
attendants of today where it's like
you're really lucky to get a drink and
like you get like a you really you don't
even get a smile like you just get like
uh knowing you're paying hundreds of
dollars no no you're paying thousands
like flight prices are so crazy a given
the current economy and B just they've
gone up yeah like you're lucky to get
out of this country for under 500 like
it's ins I mean not in the country out
of the state for under 500 like it's the
prices have gone up and every element of
service like every small luxury that you
like it's just gone yeah it's gone yeah
but I I thought that the cleaning crews
were still there especially because of
code because it's like a basic
fundamental kinds of code yeah they're
not clean airplanes right right right
don't make me call them CDC
you had a mask mandate for over a year
but you don't clean your plane it's a
good point so I'm
I'm just I'm just perplexed that that's
all I'll say yes sound off in the
comments
especially because you know a lot of our
listeners are our flight attendants
flight attendants and mamas right right
right and so what do you think but I'm
thinking about it like I'm sometimes at
a restaurant with Harry and he throws
food on the floor I was thinking of
restaurants too I he throws through it
on the floor and like I'm gonna get to
pick it up because like I I feel bad and
someone will like come and even
sometimes it's like the waiter waitress
in the room before I get to it and it's
so nice I'm like oh my gosh thank you so
much and even if they didn't do that
like I would eventually I'm not gonna go
after everything like you know maybe at
the end I'll go and get it I've seen
Olivia do but if someone like came over
with a bag and a tissue and like stood
there on my hands and knees and like
told me to do it now in front of a
restaurant full of people like that
would be humiliating yeah it would be
humiliating it it's wrong yeah I think I
I'm very much like yeah like you're
responsible for your kids for sure but
like it's wrong it's there's no reason
to humiliate someone especially someone
who's just doing their best right and I
don't know I just feel like we all just
could help like this people will help
people you know right just because it's
not your responsibility it doesn't mean
you can't help yeah it's not your like
you said it's not your job to help
someone with their bags even if helping
just means scooting it to the side with
your foot and saying Captain it's out of
the aisle yeah like I don't know
I'd love to hear from the flight
attendant
yeah because again it's important to
note like we are getting the family side
of everyone's perspective is different
right so it's entirely possible like
it's like buckets and buckets and
popcorn it was rising in the house and
the aisle right people couldn't walk
through so I maybe maybe the flight
attendant has like a totally different
perspective inside of the story yeah
like maybe they were [__] rude you
know what I mean like right you never
know maybe they were terrible passengers
I'm not saying that they were
like maybe she didn't help for a reason
you know what she was asking for it no
nothing she was asking for it but like
the kid the two-year-old was asking like
maybe these people had been rude and
terrible and yelled and but because you
really just mean the mom the mom because
the kids are kids I'm not saying by the
way she probably wasn't I'm just saying
we only are getting one half of the
story because everyone's version of
their truth is their truth yeah yeah
so I would like to see the flight
attendant come forward I would
absolutely love a sit down she's welcome
on the toast worry
or he
okay well that's the big debate of the
day yeah no and please I would like to
hear I'm not a mom so again like I but I
have traveled with a child and it's
[__] hell on so hard everybody can
like help you not make your time harder
like that's what you should be doing
yeah it's I have so much respect like
just moms need more respect and more
help and sympathy yeah not on their
hands and he's pregnant even if she
wasn't pregnant and she's just a mom
with two kids it would be bad help it
would be better it would be better but
even if she's just pregnant and didn't
have the two kids
about the pregnant thing makes it is
probably the worst part of it because to
make someone physically who's when
you're pregnant you're not at your
physical uh nobody flexibility best
flexibility say you're pregnant you're
not traveling with kids and you make a
mess and it's your mental it's your mess
to clean up um
I still think someone should help like
you're pregnant you can't bend yeah like
her getting on her knees I'm not saying
that's right but I'm just saying that's
what the comments would say clean up
after yourself pregnant once right no I
don't know so the whole thing just
confounds it yeah yeah and
makes it just bad just bad not a good
look I wonder how United will
I don't know they're not like getting
that much backlash because a lot of
people are being like cleanup yeah
so that's that on that interesting are
you ready for our next Story another
uh business that's being blasted by Tom
Sandoval yes Tom Sandoval blasts the
wellness Resort maraval for outing his
stay so we reported yesterday that
Raquel Raquel checked into a mental
health facility Claudia said she thought
it was miraval which is just like a spa
retreat in Arizona right and then some
drama went down between Tom and Mirabal
so he claimed that Maryville Arizona fed
into negativity and spectacle in his
life by posting an Instagram photo with
a caption that seemingly referenced his
affair drama they posted a picture of
their bar and the caption is you know
that it's our time these are the best
days of our life so it's like that's the
theme song from Vanderpump Rules and
they posted that while he was staying at
their facility right
he said I'm beyond disappointed in and I
guess it was rumored that he was staying
there like they were speculation in the
internet chatter yeah I'm beyond
disappointed in maraval uh and their
decision to pose their to their
Instagram account this weekend this
weekend are you okay no he's not okay he
said pose to their Instagram
sorry the transcriptionist did I'm
reading his words I'm beyond
disappointed in maraval at Mirabal and
their decision to post their Instagram
account this past weekend alluding to me
staying there this week they claim to be
a refuge for wellness and betterment but
that is obviously false they'd rather
feed into the negativity and spectacle
that has engulfed my life in a
continuous effort to be healthy and work
on myself I planned a trip to go there
completely alone to try and find some
peace maraval clearly isn't the place
for that special shout out to the
general manager who refuses to take any
responsibility for the actions of his
team even though he considered the post
quote in poor taste regardless of where
you stand in all this we all deserve the
chance to work to be better I don't
disagree I don't know that you're
working at Mirabal yeah no no the thing
is like this is just a bad look for
miraval like
it's so petty it's it's not only Petty
like he's a pen customer like you have
are have a right to privacy
no matter who you are and this is like
actually really tacky and like I don't
care because like I hate Tom Sandoval
but like it's not it's not he's not
wrong no he's not wrong I don't think it
bodes well for like other celebrities
who would want to go there and then it's
like Oh They'll blast it and also it's
not like it was from page news that he
was staying there this was sort of like
internet chatter so it's like you're
posting to your Instagram like it's not
like the whole world is talking about
Tom Sandoval at Maryville I had no idea
he was there and I'm pretty clued in
yeah so like you're what like posting
Instagram rumors to your account and you
are like this high-end Wellness brand
and you're joining in on an internet
pylon at a time when like nobody needed
to hear from you no and it's like
somebody went to your facility to seek
Refuge from an internet pylon and your
brand then decides to join in on that
pylon like it is this is like really
tacky actually yeah I think it looks
really bad for them and I think even
people who are not who are not team
Sandoval and you know you could never
confuse turdy and I as being anything
other than team Ariana yeah even before
right like we wouldn't just never find
ourselves like defending Santa and I'm
not but like
if I'm a celebrity choosing between two
wellness retreats I'm certainly not
going to maraval knowing that like my
privacy might be compromised yeah it's
really tacky and again the celebrity
like a lay person anyone it's like a
wellness so it's not this isn't a mental
health facility because if it was there
are like HIPAA and there are these
regulations in place so that things like
this don't don't happen which just
further proves that Raquel is like
actually not even close to being in any
sort of like actual mental health
facility she's going to you know
so they're both at Marathon that's what
I was confused about it was a story but
he said he went alone and he's back
already I think and she just went so
maybe he like went he said oh this was
really good for my mental health and
then she went and then highly recommend
and then her rep lied and said she was
always going right and called it a
mental health facility which we
speculated yesterday and now we know
like that is extremely misleading it's
misleading but not a lie like a mental
health facility could be a lot of things
could be your house yeah no when I think
of mental health facility like I do
think of like a sterile kind of a mental
institution yeah like a psychological I
don't know what they what the right word
is for it these days like like what like
a like a psychiatric
treatment facility
like a hospital yeah
she didn't go to a hospital that's even
if she didn't go to Maribel she didn't
check herself into it that's what it
sounds like when you say a mental health
facility honestly right but when you
break down the words mental health
facility it can be anything yeah of
course so it's a it's a it's a
manipulation of language yes which is
what I guess what a good publicist would
do right
that we're here to break it down yeah
so in regards to this mirrorable thing
like I actually do agree with Sandoval
which is not something I thought I would
ever say
um and like it just it's really like
it's tacky it and it's just losery
because it's like you dunked when like
no there was no game being played like
no one even knew he was at miraval like
no one was talking about you and now
we're talking about you in a negative
light considering what your brand is
like if you're if this was I don't know
Secrets Resort and Tom and Ari and
Raquel were rumored to be there actually
would be like an amazing partnership
continue right and they were like they
posted a sexy bar you know that yeah
it'd be like okay it's on brand yeah no
it's to like exploit where someone's
like really trying to use your facility
for it's like wellness elements like No
And also like you maraval tries to
position themselves as a wellness right
that's how they brand themselves is like
this kind of like um retreaty it's not
like a hotel or really or Spa it's this
they went there on Real Housewives like
you do sound baths and like trauma
treatment like it's it's you know very
Guru yeah yeah agreed so that's an L for
them it's not a win for Sandoval no by
any means but um and now for them yeah
our next story is a little more Pump
News because our animatics is single and
having fun including canoodling at
Coachella after her split from Tom the
Vanderpump Rules star Ariana was spotted
kissing a new man over the weekend at
Coachella a source tells people all just
for fun uh Source said Ariana just got
out of a long relationship and isn't
jumping into anything serious what
you're seeing is a woman who is single
and having fun she was featured on an
Instagram story spending time with a
fitness instructor Daniel way he also
tagged Ariana in a selfie of the two of
them waiting for Frank Ocean's
headlining performance then TMZ shared a
video of the pair kissing during the
headliner show yeah I saw that on Tick
Tock it was like so cute he's very
handsome I'm sure this is not like the
you know and I'll be all love of her
life but like you'd love to see her out
here having some fun and I also feel
like tell me if you feel this call you
know obviously ending a nine-year
relationship is probably like one of the
hardest things that you can do
um and takes a really long time to get
over that person
but when the entire world like every day
is like like hating on the guy who like
broke your heart and like makes
like doesn't it make it easier for you
to get over him like I feel like she's
probably like really over Tom I feel
like also when the bridge is so burned
to a crisp there's no longity he'll
change like it's so Crystal Clear what
happened and that there's no going back
like you can only go forward I don't
think she needs you could spend time I
think the probably the hardest thing for
her is like
the
the habitual nature of their
relationship like the house living
together living together him being you
know her best friend and co-workers and
all of those things they were doing
everything together so I think that
part's harder but I think the Romantic
piece
that's probably the easiest part to move
on from right especially because she
probably wakes up every day and like
goes to her phone and there's just like
memes and [__] being written about her
man like make him look so bad and stupid
and ugly like I don't thought I I just
have a hard time believing she could be
like longing for him you know no it's
harder to imagine Raquel still being
attracted to him than it is to imagine
Ariana moving on you know what it's
actually not hard for me to imagine
Raquel being attracted to him because
they literally have nobody else
like they're on this island together
that they created like if you're not
gonna love him like who the [__] are you
gonna talk to yeah no she really still
has I would hope like her friend like
her home friend real friends and you
know they say we know the real raccoon
yeah no for sure for sure but in terms
of this group and people who really
understand what's going on like there's
literally one person she can talk to you
know yeah
and he's the worst oh my God yeah so
glad I'm not Raquel
so anyways that's really cute I don't
think it's too soon I think she could do
whatever the [__] she don't think it's
too soon yeah I think some people were
saying that people are the worst yeah
it's lit it's literally not too soon no
and it's certainly not too soon for like
a dance floor make out at a festival
right it's not like you know a romantic
getaway like right they're like and even
if it was I think that's fine too but
like you can have in your you know
breakup era a dance floor make out yeah
it's really not a big deal no look at
Sean and Camilla right like it's just
not that serious sometimes and it's
Coachella like you know it's coachelli
like whatever it's Coachella The Vibes
surviving right that's so us it's kind
of like Vegas like it doesn't count what
happens at cochelli ends up on TMZ right
right but it's how exciting for her like
she's so [__] famous now yeah and she
was kind of like for always just like a
kind of beta cast member she never
really threw her hat in the ring that
deeply yeah she was always involved in
stuff like because of Tom and she kind
of gets to come out on the other side of
this like the biggest star on the show
everyone is obsessed with her and she's
a full-blown celebrity honestly they did
her a favor to be honest well they
definitely did her favor for multitude
of reasons our next story is a little
more Coachella news but I think turdy
has something to say is it a little bit
more Coachella news that's brought to
you by the perfect bar the perfect
Coachella snack honestly truly because
it's a long day and if you're looking
for a protein bar that actually tastes
good we'll look no further than perfect
bar their lineup of fresh from the
fridge protein bars perfect bar is
exactly what you've been looking for
there's no chalky artificial aftertaste
it's made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are also good and good for you
you'll be sure to find something you
love like the chocolate chip cookie
dough so good and again keeping it in
the fridge because it's like you know
really great and fresh we love that but
it gives it such a great texture like a
nice little crunch with that chocolate
so they keep it in the fridge because
they're made with whole food ingredients
they contain no artificial preservatives
so grab one after a workout for a quick
bite while you're shopping it's a snack
that you can feel good about
perfect bar contains up to 17 grams of
protein per bar and it comes in 10 over
10 delicious delicious flavors like that
dark chocolate chip peanut butter the
coconut peanut butter and cookie dough
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar it'll go directly into your
venmo or PayPal account it's pretty cool
all you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
t-o-a-s-t to get a free perfect bar
today happy snacking and yet welcome for
getting you free food because that's
kind of what we do it's our reason day
tear or Reason to tear today's episode
is also brought to you by vegamore we're
always trying to ripe our bodies so when
it comes to our hair and scalp Health
finding a product that actually works
and is made with clean ingredients
always seems like a trade-off but with
vegamore you can get products that are
made with clean ingredients and give us
visibly healthier hair and scalp so
again as I was talking about randomly at
the beginning of the episode just like
this journey that I've been on that's
been pretty treacherous
um when it came time to actual products
to put in my hair I was being very
Jackie on like I'm not doing crazy
chemicals nothing toxic and vegamore
came to mind immediately because they
have their grow like solution for
shampoo and conditioner that's what I'm
currently using I actually forgot to
bring it with me and I got it on
instacart oh yeah and so now I have like
full bottles here with me so that I can
have my clean shampoo and conditioner
with vagamore we are able to have
visibly thicker fuller shinier and
longer hair without all the harsh
ingredients so their products are 100
cruelty free they're never formulated
with potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or hormones what's even better
is that vegamore's value kits like the
grow Essentials kit which is what Jackie
was just talking about excuse me
sneezed on it it's true that's where you
get to try more than one amazing product
at a great savings so when you sign up
for a monthly subscription you save more
and you never run low on the products
that you need to take care of your hair
the key is consistency in your routine
for your most beautiful healthy looking
hair we use vagamore grow hair serum
daily and our scallops are flourishing
give yourself the hair you never thought
you could have with megamore for a
limited time the toasty listeners are
getting 20 off their first order by
going to vegamore.com toast and using
Code toast at checkout that's
v-e-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast to save 20 on your first order
that's
b-a-g-a-m-o-u-r.com slash toast code
toast thank you you're welcome
oh bruh
for all the codes and all the links
that'll save six six six seven save
codes and links that will save
that was so good really you really could
have headlined Coachella unlike Frank
Ocean shots fired unlike Frank Ocean who
jolted Coachella festival with an
aimless WTF headlining set in other
words his set was not good people are so
mad yeah so news has been like trickling
out about this so first we have a recap
of the set and what was seen and then
some explanation from variety so Sunday
night's Coachella headlining performance
by the enigmatic R B Star Frank Ocean
was unquestionably the most highly
anticipated set of the festival the
singer has not performed live in nearly
six years and he was set to headline the
Fest in 2020 before the pandemic and
then again last year before he postponed
it to 2023 so there were rumors of new
music coming out who he was going to
potentially bring on stage old band
mates
Etc and what they got was not that it
was very short none of this came to pass
in fact his set during which he and his
musicians were intentionally obscured by
a Cadre of people walking in a circle
around them only seen on video project
it on custom screens even more massive
than those usually flanking coachella's
main stage it was messy loose and a near
disaster that will likely go down as one
of the most divisive in Coachella
history with flashes of Brilliance that
only made for a frustrating final
outcome that of disappointment and
palpable audience what the [__] Miss
right I saw a video when he ended the
show he was just basically like oh I'm
being told where I curfew so it shows
over bye he started the settle for 57
minutes after its advertised start time
which eats into curfew time for the
venue so then that cuts off minutes on
the tail end the first five minutes were
comprised of people silently walking in
a circle leading people to wonder if he
was even gonna appear at all then his
voice came through and he sounded really
good but it was impossible to see him
behind the wall of walking people this
scavenger hunt for the headliner would
continue throughout the set to him even
after the wall of people left he and his
band were too far back on the stage too
obscured by the screens there was just a
small opening for the actual stage and
two poorly lit from the lack of stage
lights for anyone but the most perfectly
placed audience members audience members
to get more than just a cursory glance
of the musicians there were a lot of
pauses a lot of what are we doing next I
saw a bunch I saw literally his music
playing like on an aux cord and him just
standing there like I didn't even he
wasn't even singing yeah so here's what
they said happened okay why was it such
a mess
so he was supposed to apparently have an
ice ring on the stage and they were
rehearsing it like that for weeks and
the days leading up to the festival and
then I think on Sunday they had to
change they got rid of it they got rid
of the wall of people walking around him
were meant to be ice skaters but they
just turned into walls they just
transferred the choreography from Ice to
not ice yeah it was supposed to be an
elaborate Stage production involving an
ice rink and a battery of skaters it was
constructed rehearsed for several days
and ready to go but abruptly called off
on Sunday afternoon after the festival
was already underway it was not uh why
it was changed there's two explanations
citing sources the festival owl which I
guess is like a festival yes insiders
said Frank decided at the last minute
that he no longer wanted it all all the
people walking around him at the start
of the performance were actually ice
skaters have been practicing for weeks
and we're supposed to be skating
Coachella had to deconstruct the
approved stage that had been planned and
signed off on for months melt the entire
ice rink and then set it up how Frank
decided today with no warning which is
what you ended up seeing and caused for
the hour-long delay this all happened
when doors had already opened Sunday and
people were securing their spots to see
him if the last minute changes weren't
made he wouldn't have performed at all
which would have left the festival
without a closing headliner so like that
would have been crazy that situation
Coachella had no choice but to let him
go out like you know what would have
happened honestly like I honestly feel
like Justin Bieber he was there because
he's like the biggest Frank Ocean fan I
feel like they he was probably the
biggest celebrity who was there they
literally would have had to like play
get on stage we will pay you whatever
just do a show what would they have done
I don't know what I think they would
have like
I don't know what they would have done I
think it just would have been a big epic
fail yeah and I mean people might want
to get like refunds or might maybe there
would be like a case for like a class
action lawsuit for sure
but I don't think Justin Bieber's the
kind of singer who just get on stage and
start singing for two hours the thing
with the but then another report from
TMZ and rolling stone the cite a source
saying that production on his
performance was adjusted at the last
minute to account for an ankle injury
yeah the singer sustained during on-site
rehearsals in the week leading up to the
festival so I have so many thoughts the
first thing is about the curfew is I
read a report uh
Coachella Golden Voice the company that
owns it paid 200 000 to like the Palm
Springs Council for their violations
this weekend like it's just a part it's
a cost that they incur going past review
it's not the biggest deal if he had went
you get charged I think like every 10
minutes is like whatever they would have
paid it like I don't think it was that
big of a deal he wanted to leave I want
to say like this is so beyond
unacceptable and when you think about
people who have headlined Coachella in
years past and like how much they
Beyonce like how much they gave Harry
Styles last year like it's
it's like it's definitely embarrassing
for for Frank Ocean it just makes him
look so bad like when you compare like
literally seriously Beyonce that was
probably one of like the greatest
performances of all time like for the
same event they probably got paid a
similar amount like that's what you put
together and let's say this ankle thing
is true like can you could you literally
ever see like a small ankle injury
getting in Beyonce's way like that's
just what it sucks but like that's what
these performers do like they work
through tough things when you saw Lady
Gaga's documentary her chronic pain Lady
Gaga's Coachella performance I think she
was dealing with her chronic pain like
that's just I don't know it's
I don't know like The Show Must Go On
yeah also I understand not wanting to be
on an ice rink with an ankle income but
there are other ways to recalibrate the
performance one and this doesn't explain
why you're standing like backstage
basically where no one can see you and
you're writing like be out in front have
a spotlight on you and have the ice
skaters going off behind you also Frank
Ocean is known for his voice he doesn't
have to do all the drama you know like
he can still put on a sick performance
it's not like he's you know one of these
like pop stars who it's all about the
theatrics right um and without those
things you're kind of left with
what right people are there to hear him
sing so it's kind of like Adele in Vegas
like just saying right you don't need
the pyrotechnics and the dancers like
and it's nice because it's Coachella so
yeah let them do it in the back
I don't know I can imagine if I was like
a really big Frank Ocean fan like I I
honestly I don't think I know more than
one Frank Ocean song so like I I'm just
trying to get into the headspace like if
I no if I was a fan of anyone and they
were Sunday night at Coachella which is
the biggest night but also the worst
night because it means that you have to
come home Monday and you can't come home
Sunday and like you wait the whole
weekend for that one person you know and
there's so much of money and time and
energy and resources spent to get to
Coachella yeah no people camped there if
your person is Sunday night and like
you're making a trip to this Festival
because like that's your person and it's
this disappointing like
oh my God I don't think I could continue
being a fan of that person like I would
be so annoying yeah
and the interesting thing about
Coachella is that everyone forgets but
there's actually two weekends there's
another one this weekend so I don't know
what that means for for Frank Ocean's
performance do you think he'll it'll be
Redemptive or he won't perform at all I
don't know I get the vibe like he
doesn't care yeah but if he does like it
would be Redemptive it has to be he
can't do this again right
um the only other thing that I saw was
like again Justin Bieber is like a
really big Frank Ocean fan and he posted
that it was like incredible like just
kind of like defending maybe some of his
fans feel that way it's like maybe if
you saw Taylor and it wasn't like lights
camera action but it was you're watching
your girl and you love her and you liked
it yeah maybe it would be enough for you
maybe you know maybe that's a really
good point
yeah this was just like so shocking
because I feel like the Coachella
Headliners like it's Coachella like so
has it together like it's always it's
never the music that's the problem right
it's always like amazing yeah I think
the stars of the weekend were black pink
actually that's what I heard I heard
that their performance was amazing I'm
sure it was they are so amazing they're
so cute that's something I would have
liked to see yeah
so win for black pink yeah
are you ready for a fifth and final
story like kind of some shocking news
Yellowstone is set to end after the rest
of season five airs okay but this isn't
like an official announcement right no
it's like more sources but it's like
we're getting there multiple sources
have confirmed to the post that
Yellowstone is set to end after the
second half of season five I just got on
board right now it's not known when the
show will air again in fact it's not
known when it will even film the show as
we have talked about had been hit by
claims that Kevin Costner who's the star
of the show won't return amid a dispute
with Creator Taylor Sheridan it's the
same as with any showrunner and a big
star there's respect but there's
friction so it's true I just want to say
like I don't see a time in which I would
ever forgive Kevin Costner honestly
yeah but like when we first were talking
about this it was like there was going
to be a show and Kevin Costner was going
to leave at some point yeah would you
rather them continue Yellowstone without
John Dutton or end the show with him I
would like them to continue it
not forever yeah but isn't that just
like the OC without Marissa spoiler
alert no but isn't that also the point
of Yellowstone it's like a succession
thing yeah so like maybe honestly like
one season without him like what happens
after like how do and then you know
there's a resolution and then we know
that that's how Yellowstone will go on
for the next 50 years but the whole
point of the show is like the whole time
it's been like which kid is it yeah
that's a good point so I actually do
think we can get one or two seasons
without him but what yes you're right
like going on forever without like
that's terrible yeah and I hate that I
hate that too but like it's like
succession spoiler alert
you know we are now in the final season
and we are now seeing what happens in
the succession yeah you know are we even
seeing hopefully we will do you see
anything on Sunday yes about who's
succeeding yes you have an answer you
can spoil it I don't give a [__]
um
kind of you know like so yeah because
everything's uh yeah so they found a
piece of paper oh in his um in his safe
that said it's Kendall amongst a bunch
of other wishes like he wanted to leave
Colin a watch
um
but and it was actually it was a very
smart thing they did his name was
underlined
and it also kind of looks like his name
was crossed out like they can't tell
Honestly by looking at it like Logan's
not the type of guy to just crossing out
like he would burn it to the ground he
wouldn't put it back in his safe
it looked like it was underlined so they
needed they had a board thing that day
this actually sounds good so for the
interim position they all agreed to do
Kendall and Roman and like shiv got like
pushed out because it's like well to
push all three of us like you have
actually never really [__] worked for
the company like you have no experience
like Roman and I both who were both
currently like CEOs or whatever
and it would just look like we're trying
to be like family all in the company
like you need to take a step back and
she was like sure because she's like
totally getting pushed out oh and
there's like a big thing that happened
can I tell you you know what I think
I'll watch it sounds good so she got she
got she got kicked out okay good yeah
look she is they said that you're like
literally not qualified no not even when
none of them really are we tried to get
chip to work for the company like a
season or two ago because Logan had
decided to favor her in one right and it
didn't go over well right so
um in order to make it looks like to
like the shareholders they're like we
can't all three like that looks so
thirsty and they were all saying like
they'll poke holes with shiv like she is
not and she like actively rails against
the company right she's not the right
person for it I mean Kendall is
obviously odd choice too because he'd be
so publicly against his dad but he has
this piece of paper right so because he
has the paper it's like his father's
language and then Roman is honestly
Roman's been with the company
ride or die recently recently but no I
think Kendall up until the show started
he was always working for a company like
in his whole life he was always supposed
to be the next yeah like I just don't
know if this piece of paper is like
outdated because at one point it was
definitely true that's funny yeah it was
good that's so succession like no answer
yes I'm sorry but nothing yeah but
that's better than what I thought it was
going to be which was just more dialogue
no they actually had a board meeting
they had a piece of paper but it's an
interim position yeah but everybody
knows like in order to get to the
full-time position like you got to get
to the interim yeah so like shiv is
quaking
oh I love that for her yeah I kind of
like hate her yeah me too who do you
hate more Logan Kendall or [__] shiv
yeah is that like a hot dog I mean at
one point in time I definitely hated
Kendall Moore yeah I don't know
Kendall's like
it's kind of wrong yeah
Roman is like still has my heart you
know I read something what was it when
did you watch the first episode of
succession me
a year ago or two years did you know
that in the first episode
and they never bring it up again Roman
has a wife and a son or a child maybe a
daughter no yeah
and then it's just like a plot hole it's
either a plot hole or maybe it's like
not it's like that's what the rich do
you know oh Richie's gonna Rich yeah but
like he is a full ass child like so does
Kendall kennel is too but like they've
been in and out yeah yeah he doesn't
talk about them all the time no that's
part of his story yeah Roman has a child
and a white yeah but like not he's not
married we don't know
that's weird is that crazy yeah
so either it's a plot hole where
something they decided like immediately
never mind that's a weird thing I know
especially just like write it into the
script oh I'm getting divorced right
right she has full custody right I right
well I guess that's your succession
recap oh that's [__] [__] by the
way like seriously we didn't even talk
about if the show ends like not [__]
cool Kevin Costner I just got here I
know you just got here but I would be
okay if they end the show with Integrity
yeah of course it's better to have loved
and lost whatever you're not telling me
that we don't we don't even have a
season left we have half a season left
well right because they stopped for
mid-season finale and they literally
never finished but the thing is like the
way that season five is going so far
it's giving final season Vibes already
like it's so uh nostalgic and just it's
not dramatic it's kind of like just
closing yeah the threads like it's
they're constantly at like the county
fair listening to music and and enjoying
life in your eyes because I think it's
fairly obvious to me like how does the
succession of Yellowstone go like John
is getting older what happens next
uh
I think that it has to be Beth rip and
Casey they all can live there they all
do their share they each I kind of do a
third of what John was doing as a one
and then it goes to Casey Sun
but you don't think they're gonna adopt
that runaway kid I think they could in
that runaway kid could be to Casey's son
what rip was to John just because he
doesn't have done in his blood yeah yes
but no but like
I think that would be nice if if they
should foster a friendship between
Casey's son and the The Runaway right
what do they keep calling him just kid
yeah I don't know and then we could see
how in 50 years it is John and rip is
his right hand yeah
yeah maybe you know
The Runaway kid falls in love with like
if if uh Casey has a daughter maybe
right Casey has a daughter yeah I like
that I love it done yeah that's actually
really good yeah welcome Taylor it's
literally just copy and pasting yeah but
I think that would be so nice yeah
yeah it's really good
um I guess we'll just have to wait and
see but we've been saying that for a
while apparently they're not even
filming when are we gonna get the second
half of the season I feel like they
might be filming that part I feel like
they don't know [__] about [__] yeah
it's just like what is Cole Hauser gonna
do next
their spin-off talk Matthew McConaughey
four horse farm six eight six six six
six six six six no six acres
six that farm in Dallas Texas
triple six no
six shoe six horse
four star Yellow Stone the sixes I think
the sixes six just spin off Jimmy
Yellowstone sixes
everything we know about Yellowstone
spin-off
what four sixes four sixes four sixes
yeah yeah yeah
that's like didn't feel right no it
didn't feel good like when you get it
the four sixes but yeah maybe it's that
there's more in the Matthew McConaughey
show did you say that yeah like they're
saying that he's could be the next John
Dunn but I think you know I thought it
was a separate show he shouldn't come in
on Yellowstone that will ruin the show
yeah and we have 1923 which I finished
in 1883 which I truly couldn't get
through do you like 1923. um I did I
don't know if I just liked it because
that guy was
so hot and Michelle Randolph
um
so I don't know if I was like blinded by
like the sexy man and the beautiful
woman I don't think that you could be
blinded in 1923 like I feel like that
would be a hard thing for you to like
like yes except it was like very My Vibe
like so much of it takes place in Africa
and they're like these beautiful safaris
and like I love that [__] and it was
like in the in the early 1900s it was
like very glamorous you know they're all
going on so far it's like Roaring 20s
yeah I didn't it was like kind of the
vibe you know oh okay
yeah I gotta watch oh you didn't see it
no oh my god the guy is so hot like it's
literally the most important part of the
show hotter than rip no no no
no but different because these guys are
very traditionally like he was meant to
be an actor the coal Houser was probably
told like in many auditions like you're
not traditionally handsome enough you're
not like ripped enough you'll never be
the leading man right and that's what
makes him I'm not ripped enough I'll
become rich oh no he said I'm not ripped
enough I don't give a rip
I
that's why he's so in my opinion like
popping off and like women are in love
with him because he kind of looks like
just everyone's husband like yeah he's
not this like crazy crazy body like he's
just like so American no and also it's
his character that we've fallen in love
like Jack not the character of rip no no
that's not what I mean his character as
a man yeah and like we've said your
character at a certain point outweighs
your looks like I see you for what you
truly are which is ugly which could be
ugly in Rip's case it's extremely
handsome so true look at us with her
feet no I copied you it's kind of a nice
way to sit right I completely disagree
that's better it's kind of nice well
you're wearing big shoes yeah big heavy
shoes that's a heavy load to carry
um
speaking of heavy loads to carry we've
officially carried this one all the way
through for uh wow an hour 15 we went
long today wow look at us thanks Jax
thanks turdy thanks so much for
listening to the video Morning Show
we're delivering everybody they've
already on YouTube they're watching this
on YouTube subscribing this video thumbs
up Rose available Spotify
have a great day we'll see you tomorrow
for hump day yeah it was exciting I love
you bye